over the weekend we've seen some
scientists coming out to say that the
lockdown has been eased too quickly are
you concerned that politicians and no
longer following the science politicians
always have to make the decisions and
make the judgments it's not unusual for
scientists to take different views but
from the perspective of accountability I
think it's very clear that scientists
advise and politicians decide for what
it's worth I agree with the opinion that
has been expressed over the weekend that
we've got to be very cautious this virus
hasn't gone away there is still a
significant risk that it could run out
of control again that's why in Scotland
we are moving very slowly very
cautiously we've just gone into phase 1
of a route map out of lockdown and that
expressly recognizes that in that phase
that is a significant risk that the
epidemic is not fully contained so focus
has been very much on allowing some more
outdoor activity because we know that
the risks of transmission outside well
they're not zero are lower than they are
indoors and we're asking people to
continue to follow all the rules on
physical distancing at hygiene making
sure that they are not allowing the
virus to spread between households on
hard surfaces so Scotland will continue
to take a very cautious very slow and
steady route out of lockdown and we will
make sure we monitor the impact of that
all along you say that you're
prioritizing outdoor activities in
Scotland but you could also argue that
you're prioritizing social activities
over things that will kick-start the
economy eight people can out meet
outside you know you can play golf or
tennis you can go sunbathing in the park
but you don't have to get back to school
you don't have to go back to work if you
work inside I mean is this not just
doing what would be popular rather than
things that actually in the long term
will benefit the economy it's try to
take a balanced view and you know I make
no apologies for that although I have to
see you know these are judgments and
there's no absolute rights and wrongs in
all of this and all of us will meet
mistakes along the way but I do think
it's important that we get the economy
moving as quickly as it is safe to do so
I certainly want to see that as First
Minister so some outdoor work is allowed
to resume in Scotland no but you know I
also think it's really important that we
recognize the things that
matter most to people's quality of life
and that is family friendship love these
are all things that people have had to
sacrifice over the past couple of months
and I I don't think it would be right to
when we've got such limited room for
maneuver and that's the key point here
we don't have much room to spare we
don't have much flexibility so I think
it would be wrong to use all of that to
get the economy moving again and end up
in a situation where people are gone
back to work been told they have to go
back to work and remain a lockdown for
the rest of the time that wouldn't give
very much quality of life to people so
it's about trying to strike the right
balance but crucially making sure that
the steps we take are not running at the
risk of allowing the virus to spread out
of control again so this is always going
to be a difficult balance but it's the
responsibility of politicians like me to
try to get that as right as we possibly
can yeah as you say it's clearly a
political decision even if it's based on
as much science as possible in the
meetings and the briefings that you've
been a part of have you picked up a
sense recently that scientists are
worried about some of the political
decisions are being made I guess
that is probably a concern and I'm not
speaking on behalf of scientists here
because I've not had this conversation
with any of them but I think if if we
look and observe the media coverage in
recent weeks uk-wide if I was a
scientist I think I might have a little
concern that politicians were we're
looking to try to blame me for any
mistakes that had been made and I don't
think that would be right to do
politicians like me it's a it's a tough
place to be at a time of crisis like
this but we are elected and we are
accountable so we have to listen to the
Evalia it's really really important that
we listen to the scientific advice we
try to understand that as much as
possible but ultimately we have to apply
our judgment to that and take the
decisions and I think it's really
important that we are very clear about
that so do you think then just trying to
read between the lines slightly do you
think the politicians and Westminster
have been trying to hide behind the
science I'm not here to criticize other
politicians I've tried very hard through
this crisis not to do that we're all in
a really tough situation these are the
hardest decisions I've ever had to take
in my political Kitty it and I'm sure
the case for others and we're all trying
to do the right things but the point I'm
making here is a a straightforward one
you know we have within these positions
with elected to these positions to take
the tough decisions not just for the
easy times but for the the hard times as
well and I think it's really important
that that separation of responsibilities
is understood their advisors advise us
but we have to take the decisions and
and I think it's very important for all
of us to be clear about that okay now I
just want to talk to you a bit about
these situation in care homes in
Scotland because between the 16th of
March in the 24th of May there were 94
percent more deaths in Scottish care
homes than the average 46 percent of
deaths linked to coronavirus and
Scotland happened in care homes in
England and Wales that figure was just
28 percent and it does seem that you
know one of the great tragedies of the
pandemic has been the failure to protect
some of our most vulnerable people is
this a matter of personal regret for you
every single death from this foetus is a
matter of deep personal regret to me and
you know I'm sure again I I'm not the
only leader that says some of these
decisions and the implications of what
has happened over the past couple of
months will live with me for probably
the rest of of my life but can I just
look at the situation in care homes
specifically because it's often put to
me that the death rate for one of a
better expression and care homes in
Scotland is higher than it is in England
and I just don't believe that that is
the case and I should preface my comment
here by saying I don't think any level
of this is acceptable and it shouldn't
be a competition excess deaths in
Scotland over all but also in care homes
is lower than in England but more of
them are in care homes have been
attributed to Cove it than is the case
in England so about 70 percent or
something more than that of excess
deaths in Scotland are attributed to
Cove it will ask for some reason is less
than 50 percent in England in Scotland
if you die of say a stroke but you also
happen to have the virus you will be
included in the the deaths from covered
so it's not for me to explain England's
figures but I think here that is at
least on the face of it a question of
under
courting in England I'm confident the
Scotland's figures are robust and the
percentage of overall death of sadly and
tragically happened in care homes in
Scotland is much more than Lane with
some of the figures we see in other
countries as well whatever happens and I
accept your point on you know different
nations having different ways of
recording things 94 percent more deaths
in Scottish care homes I mean this is a
huge number of people just as in England
as well you talk about political
decisions earlier just as in England the
the Scottish government moved people
from hospitals to care homes in order to
free up space in hospitals for what you
warned could be a tsunami of cobia
patients in March 921 patients in
Scotland sent from hospital to care
homes was that a mistake
I think it's very easy right now and to
some extent understandable because this
is so tragic and grim and horrible to
look back and apply the knowledge we
have now to the decisions we took then
and I think it is right that there is
full consideration and in due course and
full scrutiny of these decisions so that
that is accountability but also that we
learn lessons for the future but if I
can take you back to that earlier period
and consider the fact that the older
people that were in hospital the
so-called delayed discharges they didn't
need to be in hospital they had no
medical need to be in hospital we were
expecting and in some cases saw an
influx of coronavirus patients into
hospitals it would have been unthinkable
simply to leave older patients will be
weird and Hospital that would also have
put them at serious and significant risk
so what we did was put in place a system
of risk assessment for older people
being discharged from hospitals and give
guidance to care home providers about
the isolation and infection prevention
and control procedures they should have
been following so my point is not the
port has happened in care homes as
anything other than tragic and needs to
be carefully and seriously considered
it's simply that at all times that I can
only speak for myself and my government
we have sought to take the best
decisions we could based on the
knowledge and information we had at the
time you know in the period since we've
learned so much about this virus that we
simply didn't know then chief amongst
those things pause
is the risks of asymptomatic
transmission back then the view was that
people who didn't have symptoms either
because they were pre symptomatic or
asymptomatic didn't shed the virus we've
got a very different understanding of it
now so as our knowledge has developed
we've tried to adapt the response that
we have as well and you were saying that
it would have been unthinkable to have
left some of these vulnerable people in
hospitals or where they could have
contracted cope of 19 but of course
other risks of moving them to care homes
if that's really I said 19 well and on
March the 26th the advice from the the
guidance from the Scottish government
was that individuals being discharged
from hospital do not routinely need
confirmation of a negative covert test I
mean that wasn't changed until April the
22nd we accept that that was a major
yeah well again that's the point I'm
making about knowledge changing so back
then rightly or wrongly the there wasn't
the same understanding of asymptomatic
transmission so what you know people
like me would advise back then is that
the tests weren't reliable in people who
didn't have symptoms now I should say
was it wasn't an area it's a question
was it a mistake to not know I'm clearly
testing whirlpool if I apply the
knowledge I have know then you can lead
it lead you to that conclusion but I
didn't have the knowledge that I have
know back then and that is not me trying
to make excuses believe you me I am NOT
interested in that I'm simply making the
point that we've got a virus here there
is new unique unprecedented it's still
only 150 or so days old and we have been
learning about it all along so if I take
what we know now about asymptomatic
transmission and apply that to that
period then we may well have taken
different decisions but we didn't have
that knowledge then and that's the key
point here at all stages we've taken the
best decisions based on the information
we had but you know trust me I'm not
saying for a second that I don't deeply
regret every single death from this
virus is absolutely awful
the number of people and older people in
particular who've lost the lies to this
virus and and I guess that's why I keep
saying to people please continue to
follow the guidance and the rules
because the virus hasn't gone
and it's really important that we don't
become complacent in the face of it just
a quick thought to you and you're saying
there about how important it is for
people to follow the guidance and the
rules when that rule were simply to stay
at home it's quite easy now of course
things more nuanced as the lockdown
measures start to be changed and it's a
matter of regret that we aren't seeing
exactly the same rules across all
nations of the United Kingdom as we move
out the lockdown look I think we have to
all take the decisions we think Caray
and try to collaborate and share our
views as much as possible and you know
that's the nature of devolution but it
is also frankly in the nature of a virus
that perhaps is at different stages in
different parts of the UK so you know we
what I've always been at pains to see is
it because we're taking different
decisions in Scotland just as the Welsh
government have taken different
decisions as is the Northern Irish
government it doesn't well firstly it's
not political or constitutional and it
doesn't mean that we don't continue to
try to coordinate our decisions across
the UK for nations of the UK as much as
we can